The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality,
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right,
welcome back to 6.890.
Today we continue our theme
of reductions-- NP-hardness
reductions from three partition.
Yesterday we saw a couple of
different reductions from three
partition and then a
bunch of reductions
from those problems,
various puzzles.
The last one we covered was
packing squares into a square.
This is just a reminder
visually of what it looks like.
But we're going to just
take this result as given.
And our first
NP-hardness reduction
will be from packing
squares into a square.
And then we will see
a bunch of-- possibly
as many as eight-- reductions
from three partition.
So without further
ado, let's get started.
The first problem we're
going to talk about
is edge-unfolding polyhedra.
This is a geometric
folding problem.
So if you're interested in
more, you can take 6.849.
But here's a simple-- if you've
ever made a cube out of paper,
probably you cut
out a cross shape
and then folded
it into the cube.
But if you want to know
what shape should I cut out
to make a cube, then
you want to know
where should I cut, which
edges of the cube should I cut?
They're drawn in red here.
So that, when I unfold it,
I get one connected piece
without overlap.
So for surfaces that are
topologically a sphere,
you want to cut along a
spanning tree of the edges.
And for a cube, that
will always work.
But for some polyhedra like
these two, when you unfold,
you get overlap.
And in fact, no
matter which spanning
tree of the edges you take for
either of these two polyhedra,
you're guaranteed to fail.
You cannot make these out of
one piece of paper by folding
and get an exact cover.
So that's bad news.
And these are old results.
These are back in 1998.
But it remained an
open problem, how many
other examples are there?
If I give you a polyhedron, I
want to know is there an edge
unfolding?
We only cut along the edges.
What's the complexity of that?
And the answer is, it's
NP-complete, strongly
NP-complete, slightly stronger.
This is not, obviously,
a number problem.
But in geometry,
you have this issue
of what are the coordinates
of the vertices.
So the coordinates could
be exponentially large
or they could just be
polynomially large.
Here they only be polynomially
large, so strongly NP-complete.
This is a complicated
proof so I'm just
going to sketch the
idea of how it works.
At the beginning,
like most proofs,
there's some kind of like
overall infrastructure
the holds all the
pieces together.
This is one part of that.
Well, this is the
main infrastructure
in this reduction.
There's some stuff
around the side.
This is mainly to make the
surface topologically a sphere.
The focus is on a
square face here
that has a little slit in it.
And there's a tower coming out.
It's drawn edge-on here.
This is the part we
actually care about.
I think, actually, it
will be redrawn here.
So we'll really just
be thinking about this.
And then, there's some
stuff that wraps around
it makes it a sphere
without changing unfoldings
So don't worry too
much about that.
Mainly we have this
giant-- think of it
as an obstacle
because we are not
allowed to overlap when
we unfold this thing.
So this shape can't
be cut up because it
has no edges except for here.
So this part can move around it.
It turns out that it
can just stay in there
but it might move up.
So we'll make a little
bit of space here.
There's this hole of this face.
Then there is this tower
that is sticking out
into the third dimension and
we need to somehow unfold
that thing and fit it in here.
Doesn't look possible
because this is not
quite drawn to scale.
This is going to be super long.
So a lot of the stuff here
is just going to be stuffed
up the chimney, so to speak,
but also on the surface
there is more stuff going on.
So let's zoom into this thing.
If we unfold that
tower into a plus sign.
Most of it is lots
of tiny stuff called
atoms, which we will get to.
And then, the interesting
part from a three partition
standpoint-- or sorry, from
a square packing standpoint--
is there are some square faces.
And because we're edge
cutting our surface
those squares will
remain squares.
There's no edges on them.
So those guys somehow have to
move around when you unfold.
And it's not drawn this
way, but the squares
are large enough that they
can't fit up the chimney.
OK, this chimney's actually
pretty narrow, constant width,
and those guys are
all really big.
So this other stuff can
move up the chimney,
but the squares will have
to stay in this square.
And that's how
we're going to get
packing squares into squares.
OK?
Now, the challenge is, what
we want to be able to do
is move the squares
around freely.
But in reality, we need to
make a connected 2D shape.
So somehow, we need to
connect together these squares
by some stuff-- that's
the mystery atoms--
so that, basically,
for any square packing,
we can arrange to
have those faces
in that rough arrangement.
And then the other stuff somehow
connects everything together.
And whatever doesn't fit in
here goes up the chimney.
So that's the plan.
If we zoom in--
all right, so this
is sort of the
diagram of that plan.
Imagine you have some
placement of the squares.
And we're going to try to
connect all the pieces together
maybe to some common root
in the lower left corner.
First we're just going to
draw some L's conceptually
to connect them all to here.
Those cross, which
is not allowed.
But then we're going to
reroute the L's to go around
the-- so, to get up
to this box, we're
going to go around all
the other boxes below it.
And in this way, we get a
non-crossing arrangement.
If we zoom in even closer,
these, I've drawn as lines,
but really they're
little strips of paper.
And they may do weird things
like zigzag back and forth.
How that happens
we'll see in a moment.
But this is to
convince you that,
at least if we
could place squares
and they're not like
right touching each other.
So we're going to shrink
each square a tiny bit,
which I won't get
into the details.
But if they're integer
square, let's say,
then we'll shrink them, maybe,
by minus 1 over n or something
polynomially small.
And then, that gives
us a little bit of room
to route all of these paths
if make them like 1 over n
squared or 1 over n
cubed in thickness.
Still polynomial, so
still strongly NP-hard.
So if we have a
square packing, we
can connect them
all up in this way
if we have these
magical atoms that
can do whatever we want freely.
And that's the-- so, in a little
more detail, in this picture,
we imagine the atoms as somehow
being connected together
in a chain, potentially.
And then when they unfold,
this is the fun part.
So we maybe-- for
connectivity purposes,
maybe first we want to visit
B1, then we want to visit B2,
and so on.
And that corresponds
to some traversal
on the surface of this
plus sign or the tower
that's sticking out.
And then, in 2D
when we unfold it,
we have a different thing
in mind of whether we
want it to go left or right.
So there's moving left or right
intrinsically on the surface.
And then there's moving left
and right in the unfolding.
So two separate things.
And conveniently,
this one structure
is one of these boxes-- this
is what we call the atom- can
do all of those things.
Certainly not obvious
from the picture,
it's just a little bumpy square.
But you just trial the cases,
these are three of the cases.
Not obvious, but there
turn out to be 10
after you remove
reflections and rotations.
There's a few things going on,
but the main thing going on
is whether you're going left or
right in the-- let me get this
straight-- whether you're going
left or right intrinsically
on the surface and whether
you're going left or right
or straight in the unfolding.
So here you can see you're
turning left in the unfolding,
you're going straight
in the unfolding,
and you're turning
left in the unfolding.
So the second coordinate
is L, S, and L.
What's less obvious
is if you fold this up
and you get the atom
structure, but the thing
that you attach to here
is on the folded structure
either to the left or to
the left or to the right.
So you just check
all these things.
And then, this is like
a universal glue that
can connect together the
squares however you want,
both on the surface where they
have to be connected originally
and in the unfolding
where you want
to match some square packing.
So we'll have a little bit of
hand waving there, lots of hand
waving, but in the end, you
get NP-strong, NP-completeness
of edge-unfolding polyhedra.
Any questions?
All right, perfectly
clear, then?
Let's move to another puzzle.
This is called the snake cube
puzzle or the cubra puzzle.
Here is one instantiation of it.
So we have-- it's
a chain of blocks--
I'm going to try to
unfold it in a way
that I can put it back
together, because it's actually
quite tricky to solve.
It's a chain of
blocks and there's
an elastic through the centers,
going through the center
of the faces.
And so, the result is you can't
really pull the squares apart,
it's a pretty tights elastic.
But you can spin.
Because from the
elastics point-of-view,
these are all equally happy.
So you're basically told
that-- I could also spin here,
but it doesn't do anything if
I stop at a 90 degree angle.
So I'm forced to
be straight here.
And then I'm forced to
have a 90 degree turn.
And then I'm forced to go
straight and then have a 90
degree turn and then go straight
and then have a 90 degree turn.
Here I have a few 90
degree turns in a row.
And that's the
general structure.
And can I still solve it?
Maybe.
The goal is to get into a cube.
And there are a bunch of
different versions, plastic,
wood, whatever.
This one is not solved and
so I will not do so well,
but you get an idea
of what it looks
like in its sort of flat state.
I can make it into
a kind of staircase.
So in general, this puzzle
is specified by a sequence
of lengths of straits.
And then, in between
those lengths
are the 90 degree turns.
OK?
So that's the puzzle,
pretty simple specification.
And your goal is to
fold it into a cube.
You know how big the cube is.
You just take the
number of little cubes
and take the cube root.
So this puzzle maybe goes, is at
least 1990, but could be older.
We don't know exactly.
And this puzzle is
also NP-complete.
And this proof is
also complicated
so we won't see all the details.
But this one, we'll probably
see a little bit clearer.
This is a proof by, in
particular, the three of us
and Marty in the back,
so all four of us.
And let's see, so this
doesn't look like a cube.
So lets-- before we try to
solve the problem of folding
into a cube shape, let's suppose
I give you one of these chains
and I want to know, can
it fold into this shape?
Let's say this is the target.
So it's a big box down here.
I think we call it the hub.
And then there are these
spokes, or just big boxes,
long boxes, sticking
out of the hub.
There's a hold here.
They're connected to
the main structure.
And you want to fold that.
And let's see, so
the big idea-- we're
reducing from three
partition here--
we're going to represent a
number, ai, as a zigzag--
well, sorry, shouldn't
call it a zigzag--
but we have a really long
bar, then a length 1 bar.
And then a really long
bar and a length 1 bar.
I'm drawing sort of
the thinned version.
This is really a little cube.
This is a little cube.
These are lots of cubes,
huge number of cubes.
OK?
So that's really, really big.
So big that the only
place it could fit
is down one of these spokes.
So of course, the idea is
these represent our triples
whose sum is equal to t.
And so, we have to
take these things
and because these
are so short, you
can't like go out of one
hub and jump to the next one
because there's a gap
there that's bigger than 1.
So once you commit to having
one of these long bars
into one of these
pockets, then all of them
have to go into the pockets.
So this is, in general, a big
issue with three partition
proofs is you want to
represent the number ai
in some way that's
not divisible.
If you could take
ai and split it
into two parts, than the
packing problem becomes trivial.
You'd split everything
into units or something.
So we have to make sure
ai remains a single chunk.
We are, of course, encoding
ai in your unary here,
because we have one
long bar per each ai.
But for three
partition, unary is OK.
There's some things going
on here a little bit weird.
So you see this thing is
occupying the full length.
And the length here is going
to be 8 times the target sum
instead of just the target sum.
And we're multiplying this by 8.
So those are equal, we're fine.
There's a reason for the
8 which we will get to.
OK, now, like the
previous proof,
the edge-unfolding polyhedra,
we have these great units.
And we just like them
to be free floating.
And if you generalize this
puzzle little bit and say,
well, actually, I don't
just have one chain.
I have two chains.
Or I have n chains.
And together, collectively, they
have to fold into this shape,
then we're done except that
you would remove the box,
the box over here.
Because then, these
guys just somehow
have to be assigned to these
little pockets and we're happy.
OK.
All of these numbers--
although again,
not drawn to scale--
all these numbers
are much smaller than huge.
So you can't like take
this guy and put it here,
even though in this
picture it looks
like you might be able to.
All right.
So the issue is, now we want
to connect this together
into one big chain.
We have these units.
For each i, we have
one of these units.
That's cool.
And we want to
attach them together
in a way that is
super flexible, just
like the atoms we had before.
Now we're going to
use something which
we called the zigzag,
that's why I didn't
want to call this a zigzag.
This is all unit segments.
So you have 90 degree turn, 90
degree turn, 90 degree turn,
90 degree turn.
No straits.
This turns out to be
universal in a strong sense.
It can fold into anything.
And so, we can use it to
connect these parts together.
So what we're going to
do is have the A1 gadget.
Then we're going to have
a whole bunch of zigzags
so you can go wherever
you need to go.
And then we'll
have the A2 gadget.
And then we'll have
the universal zigzag
gadget for a long length of it.
And then the A3.
And then alternating
between zigzags and the ai.
And at the end, we'll
have enough zigzag
that we can fill all this
sort of extra garbage space.
But we will use this garbage
space in order to route around.
So maybe A1's going to go here.
And so we do this
thing, this, yeah,
looks like some kind of cooker.
We go back and forth like that.
Then we'll have the
zigzag and say, OK, I
want to go over here next.
And then we'll do A2 there.
And then we'll route over here.
And because this is in 3D,
crossings are not an issue.
I can just got out into
the third dimension.
We don't need much of a
third dimension, 8 is enough.
You can just, enough
to go over each other.
OK.
And then at the end,
we're going to fill in all
this space with the zigzag.
So let's talk about the zigzag.
What we claim-- there's
a couple different senses
in which it's universal.
But the key idea are
these sets of gadgets.
So we're drawing
here a two by two
by two cube made up
of 8 little cubes.
And if you look at the--
what we've drawn here
is the elastic that goes through
the centers of the cubes.
And notice it turns 90
degrees at every voxel,
at every little cube.
So this is part of-- these
are zigzag constructions.
So what we want to
say is that, if you
sort of-- so one
sense of universality
is that the zigzag
structure can fold
into any polycube structure.
Polycube is the 3D
generalization of polyominoes
that we saw last time
from polyominoe packing.
That's not true.
But if you take any
polycube structure
and you just scale
it by a factor of 2--
so you replace
every cube with a 2
by 2 by 2 grid
like this picture--
then it's still not true.
But it's better.
So what's true at that point
is if you take any path of two
by two by two
cubes, this is what
we would call a
Hamiltonian shape,
because there's one path
that visits everything
with no collisions.
So it has to be a path that
does not hit itself in 3D.
Then you can follow
these gadgets
in order to make any
turns you need to do.
Or you can go straight,
everything is possible.
I will talk a little bit
more about that in a moment.
So 2 by 2 by 2 refinement,
meaning scaling everything
by a factor of 2,
allows the zigzag
to make any Hamiltonian
shape scaled by 2.
But that's Hamiltonian shapes.
Now conveniently,
there's this theorem
which is used a lot in
computational geometry
and we use it in
this harness proof,
that if you take any shape and
you refine it by two by two
by two, every scale
by a factor of 2, then
it becomes Hamiltonian
by a similar kind
of gadget construction.
Although it's easier-- if you
just want Hamiltonian paths,
you don't care about
where you're turning
and where you're not turning,
so that's a pretty easy proof
left as an exercise to
you and sort of an aside
from this issue.
So we take any shape we 2 by
2 by 2, refine it, we make it
Hamiltonian.
Then we two by two
refine it again.
In total 4 by 4 by 4 refinement.
And then, a zigzag path can
make that polycube shape.
And this is for any polycube.
So that's cool.
Now, I'll mention
here in this proof,
one of the issues which
we'll see a bunch of times,
I'm just going to
mention it here,
is we have a parity issue
because the cubicle grid is
two-colorable, right,
you can checkerboard
the 3D grid of squares.
And so, what that
means is every time
you go from one cube on the grid
to another cube on the grid,
you're switching parity.
If you checkerboard the
3D space black and white,
you're always going from white
to black, then black to white,
then black to white, sorry,
alternating black and white,
easier to do than to say.
And so, that's a constraint.
So for example, it is impossible
in a 2 by 2 by 2 thing,
to enter from this
cube, the front cube,
and exit from this one just
by a counting argument.
So you start, let's say
this is a black cube.
This one also a black cube.
And so, you start black and
then you alternate black, white,
black, white, and
there's 8 things to visit
and you want to end black,
that's not possible.
You have to end white.
So if you enter on a black cube,
you will leave on a white cube.
And if you enter
on a while cube,
you will leave on a black cube.
So that's a constraint.
Doesn't really get
in the way here,
but it's something you
have to keep track of.
And the theorem
wouldn't be-- what
you'd like to say is, well,
I can enter from any cube
and leave from any cube.
And you could actually
prove that by induction,
except the base
case would be wrong.
So this is something
to be careful about.
This is the base case.
This is 1 cube, can I
enter from anywhere?
One 2 by 2 by 2
super cube, can I
enter anywhere, leave anywhere?
The answer is no, but
I can enter and exit
anywhere that have
the right parity.
So if the entrance
cubes and the exit cubes
have opposite parity, then this
is actually all of the cases.
These four are where the
entrance and exit cube
are adjacent to each other.
And these two cases are
where they're opposite
from each other, not touching.
And that's all the cases
with all the rotations
and reflections.
So once you prove that, base
case is actually really easy
to do by induction, you
just are essentially
pasting all these things
together to make any path.
And then we could make
any Hamiltonian shape.
And then further refinement,
any shape becomes Hamiltonian.
So that's how we prove
zigzags are universal.
And this connects together
all of these gadgets.
There's really two
gadgets in this proof,
the ai gadgets--
there's n of n copies
of that-- and the
zigzag gadget--
there's n copies
of that as well.
Now there are some
details to check
here, of course, that the
zigzag gadgets can actually
navigate around and not cross
each other with height, 8,
and that at the end, you can
fill all the blank space.
If you're just organized
about how you traverse each
of the ai's and where
you put the blank space,
I think we just
leave some headroom.
So you can just go
up, walk over to where
all the blank space is, just
serve do a scan line traversal.
Wherever there's blank
space, you eat it up
with your zigzag at the end.
So what this does is it
let's the ai's move around
completely freely.
There shouldn't be any
constraints on how the ai's
are assigned to these pockets.
Because we want every solution
to the three partition instance
to work here.
And the zigzags let us do that
because they're so universal.
Cool?
So I think that's what I
wanted to say about this proof.
Double check my notes.
Ah, there was one
other thing which
I found a little funny
re-reading this paper is why 8?
Because we know everything has
to scale up by a factor of 4.
And that's all we're
doing in some sense.
But we do make these-- we scale
all the ai's by a factor of 8.
Not a big deal, but
there's a reason for 8.
If we just did 4 and
say-- so we want to go,
so this thing gets mapped onto
here and we go out and back
and out and back.
If we just did it
four times, we would
be arriving at basically
the same position in the 4
by 4 by 4 block.
Or sorry, we would be
arriving at the same 4
by 4 by 4 block that
we started from.
And that's not good because we
can only visit a block once.
So this is sort of an interface
issue between the zigzag--
which is nice and
universal, you can always
paste two of these
chains together,
no problem-- with this thing,
which is not universal.
It folds into
basically this shape.
That's it.
So we need to make
sure that, I mean,
we can universally do
whatever we want in here.
But we need to
make sure that when
we connect between this
zigzag structure and then
we paste in one of these
and then we come back,
that we do that in a valid
way from the perspective
of this big trunk
So the factor of 8
makes sure that if we leave
from one 4 by 4 by 4 chunk,
we come back on a different one.
And then it's easy to paste
all the paths together.
So that is [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So, I don't
quite see that this
proves that snake cube is NP.
PROFESSOR: Right.
Ah, yeah there's one
more issue, which
is this was folding this shape.
But we want to fold a cube.
Yeah.
This is the kind of
annoying part of the proof.
It's very hard to draw.
This isn't my attempt
at drawing it.
And yeah, I will
sketch the idea.
I tell you, the first part is
conceptually easy, again, hard
to draw.
The issue is forcing this
chain of blocks to do anything.
And one key idea is
if you want to fold,
let's say, a k by
k by k box, if you
have a straight
path of length k,
there aren't very many
places you can put that.
I mean, I guess there are still
k or there's k squared of them.
But you have to start
and end at the beginning
and end of the
overall cube, if you
have a full length of straight.
So the first step we do
is take your-- sorry,
this is the first step.
It's upside down because we're
doing things in reverse order.
First thing we do is
we take a target cube
and we're basically going to
have a lot of really long guys
will force you to in a row.
And you see then these
kinds of puzzles.
You tend to have straits
of length 3 like this.
These are three 3's in a row.
And we're making a
3 by 3 by 3 cube.
So that sort of has to live in,
well, it can do weird things.
But it's relatively restricted.
Maybe you can do
something like this.
But then, these must be the
edges of the cube in that case.
So we have a bunch of
those and lots of care,
and we end up reducing
the cube to a box,
meaning we cover
all of the cube.
We're forced to cover
all of the cubic
and leave exactly a box behind.
Sort of like what we did when we
were doing squares into square.
We put a bunch of big boxes
that were relatively constrained
and it just left empty
space, which is a box.
Here it's actually
forced exactly.
Then, once we have a box, so
the box will be this wide.
And it will go over this way.
But it won't have this
sort of fine feature stuff.
This will just all be
filled in as a box.
Then this step that's drawn
is to carve out this hub
and spoke shape.
And that's based on a
structure like this.
We have a huge thing.
And then a relatively
short thing of length
about 8t, And then we go down.
And then immediately back up.
And then over and
down and up and so on.
And that roughly carves
out this structure.
Now, you have to be careful
that this is actually unique.
This is why we only want the
height of this box to be 8,
because then you can't go
out of plane very much.
And while this is short,
it's longer than 8
if t is bigger than 1.
So you can't have
this spoke go up.
So it does have to
live in a plane.
Sounds right.
And this is much
smaller than huge,
so you can't fold
it some other way.
So that's pretty much forced.
And then we have to get rid of
the other seven planes, which
we do with really long guys.
Unfortunately, we don't
have all of that drawn,
so it's especially hard to see.
But this is a rough idea
of how you start with a box
and you do these sort of
infrastructure gadgets
to just carve out
the shape you want.
And then you go into the
interesting part of the chain.
This is all at the
beginning of the chain.
And as you show, it's
forced to do all this.
And then we start say here
with some zigzag and then
an ai gadget and so on.
Whew.
Easy, right?
So, you do see
here, I would say,
a very algorithmic approach.
I mean, this idea of showing
that zigzags are universal,
they can make any
shape, this is something
we do in computational
geometry all the time.
We prove that these
folding structures
fold into whatever we want.
So we're-- and we hadn't
prove this one before,
but we were armed with a lot of
algorithmic tools to do this.
And that let us
do this reduction.
So lower bounds in
our case is really
all about designing the
right algorithms to give you
powerful gadgets like this.
That's why this is the class
called algorithmic lower bound.
Other questions
about snake cubes?
Adam.
AUDIENCE: Why 8 instead of 6?
PROFESSOR: I think we want
it to be a multiple of 4
so that it's compatible
with the grid.
6, yeah, that seems cleaner.
That way we can predict
if we leave on this 4 by 4
by 4 thing, we know which
one we'll come back on.
Whereas, if it could be
in a half-grid position,
that would be messy.
Other questions?
You might be able to
make that to work,
but the advantage of hardness
proofs, because it's not
a real algorithm.
I mean, it's an algorithm
that you'd want to run.
The point is to show
this problem is hard.
You can be inefficient
in lots of places.
As long as it's
still polynomial,
it doesn't really matter.
Except for drawing
the pictures, that's
one place where it matters.
All right.
That's snake cubes.
I'm gonna go on to
another packing problem.
So we've seen rectangles into
squares, squares into squares,
how about circles into squares?
So this is a real
life puzzle where
you have these-- I think they're
water jet cut or laser cut--
metal disks.
And you have to fit
them into this box.
So these are real life puzzles.
That's one motivation.
There's a stronger motivation
for studying this problem,
because it's related to
computational origami.
There's this method called the
tree method of origami design.
If you're interested
in it, you can
take 6.849 or read Robert Lang's
book, Origami Design Secrets.
And basically, it lets
you fold things like this.
That's at a high level.
And a key component of it is
to pack disks into a square.
The square is your
piece of paper.
The disks correspond to sort
of the limbs of your creature.
And you can't use the
same piece of paper
to represent this
limb and this limb,
so the disks have
to be disjoint.
So it's all about packing
those disks into given square.
And yeah, so that's
at a high level
why we care about disk packing.
And people have thought
about disk packing a lot.
But surprisingly, it
hadn't been proofed
hard until four years ago.
So this proof is
also complicated.
And it involves a lot of
geometry and trigonometry
and some calculus and fun stuff.
So I'm going to give
you a sketch of it.
You should be believable
that this works,
but the details,
again, are messy.
For starters, let's say
that we're packing disks
into an equilateral triangle.
This is much easier
to work with.
I'll go to a square in a second.
So if I have this
equilateral triangle, what
I'm going to do is,
first, I'm going
to give you a
bunch of disks that
are forced to pack in this nice,
triangular, grid arrangement,
leaving these dark holes.
And I'm going to
give you more disks,
and so the more disks have
to go into those holes.
And these are actually kissing
disks, they're touching.
So you can only put-- every
disk you put from now on
will be in one of these holes.
And I'm just going to do this
big enough so that I have
at least n over three holes.
Each hole is going
to represent a bin
that I'm trying to put a
triple of numbers into.
And then, here is the
construction for, I guess,
this would be a three
partition gadget.
We want to get that-- oh, slight
typo there-- ai plus aj plus ak
is less than or equal to t.
And so, these are
the three disks
representing ai, aj, and ak.
And there's an extra
disk in the center.
And what's drawn here is
everything is maybe tight,
almost as touching.
But we're going to shrink
these disks a little bit--
or rather, I'm going
to shrink-- yeah,
I guess I'll shrink--
I'll get this right-- I'm
going to shrink this
disk a little bit.
And I'm going to make
these one's a little bit
bigger according
to the ai values.
So this one will be
proportional to ak larger
than the disk that
would perfectly
fit here if this one
was maximally-sized.
And so, that's going to
force this guy to move away.
Well, he's a little
bit shrunk, so maybe he
doesn't have to move away.
But this center disk,
when it shrunk down,
it has a little
bit of flexibility.
It could move more this way.
And if this disk is smaller,
it will move more this way.
It could move more this
way, more this way.
And in general, you show
that-- so these guys
are sort of placing demands
by being a little bit bigger.
They need to push out.
And this one is a
little bit smaller.
And its size is just
a function of t.
And so, it's going
to move around.
And the claim is, it has a
valid position if and only
if ai plus aj plus ak is
less than or equal to t.
I have written down a
little bit of the details.
So we're going to choose some
big number capital N, maybe
it's like n to the 100,
little n to the 100, something
like that.
And we'll shrink the
big disk by that amount.
I'm going to scale everything
so that t equals 1.
That will simplify
things a little bit.
So just shrink everything,
all the values, down,
divide everything
by t, ai's in the t.
And then, I think we're going
to shrink the ai disk by minus 1
over n squared plus ai over n.
This is a funny
notion of shrink.
I'm going to first make it
smaller by 1 over n squared.
And then I'm going to
grow it by ai over n.
This term, I believe,
is to get rid
of smaller things in
the Taylor expansion.
So disks are annoying
because they're circular.
Because they're
quadratic curves.
And so, you get-- you know, it's
an awkward shape to deal with.
And you're worried about
how I move this center
relative to how I
move the other centers
and whether they're
hitting each other.
And whether hitting each other
is a quadratic constraint.
You have to measure the distance
between these two points.
It should be greater than or
equal to the sum of the radii.
So that's tough to work with.
So to simplify things,
we take first derivatives
and say, well, to the first
order, what's happening
when I move these disks around?
And when you say
first derivatives,
you get an approximation
to the truth.
And the second derivative, it
tells you a little bit more
of the truth.
And if you've ever
done Taylor series,
you know you get
something like 1
over n, something times 1 over
n plus something times 1 over n
squared and so on.
And so, if we just
subtract off this term,
make these disks a little bit
smaller than they need to be,
that lets you deal with all
those terms all at once.
So it lets us focus
on the lead term.
And to the first order, the
claim is, what happens is,
well, we made this
disk smaller by 1.
Remember 1 is t.
We made the other
guys larger by ai.
So that's going to
work out exactly
when the sum of the three ai's
is less than or equal to 1.
Then this will have room.
And that's true to
the first order.
And you have to do
this ugly business
to make it true exactly.
So I think, without going
into vector algebra,
this is the intuition
of what's going on.
And that's that proof.
Any questions?
The point here is to expose
you to lots of different ways
to represent numbers
and three partition.
And a lot of times it comes
up in geometric settings.
But so far, we've seen rather
different ways to represent it.
We'll see graph
theory in a moment.
Probably, next up is
games and puzzles.
So let's play some games.
Right, there was one more
part of this proof I forgot.
What if you're
packing into a square?
This is particularly
important for origami.
This paper appeared in
an origami conference,
so we needed to solve the
case of square packing.
This is more awkward.
The idea, because you can't make
a nice, regular grid on a-- you
know, square grid packing is
not very efficient for disks.
But if you have these
four really big disks,
I should mention here
the goal is for the disks
to fit-- the centers of the
disks to fit inside the square.
That turns out to be
the right constraint
from an origami perspective.
So, we would make
these four big disks,
they have to be at the corners.
Then we make this big disk,
it has to be in the center.
These are all
perfectly touching.
Then we add these
four disks and it
forces a particular
arrangement here,
which is a little awkward
to compute but you can.
And yes, we do that four times.
Then, for each of
these constructions,
this is the shape that we want.
We want these kind of
equilateral triangle-ish gaps.
I say ish because they're
not straight sides,
they're arc sides.
But it is-- the centers form an
equilateral triangle perfectly.
Then we recurse.
So wherever we have a gap like
that, which is this thing,
then we add the center guy.
And then we add these
four disks again,
just like over here,
three times now.
Now, of course, we can't
force the disks to go here.
But they will.
This is a very
symmetric construction.
So we're going to do
this symmetrically in all
the things.
The other challenge is we left
these rather large gaps here.
I mean, relative to
these tiny disks,
which are all fit inside that
gap, this is pretty big gap.
So we also have
to make these gaps
unusable by adding
a maximal disk
and then adding maximal disk.
And just recursively
adding maximal disks
until the gaps that are left
are tinier than all the ones
that we're going to
produce in this recursion.
This recursion has depth
like log n, so in the end,
we get roughly n of
these things or n over 3.
If we have extras, we'll
just throw in maximum disks
and make them unusable.
So that's it.
So this is a lot
harder because you
have to fill in
all of these gaps
and make sure everything
is going to be happy.
And no disk can go
in the wrong place.
But if you sort of do
it in the right order,
you can be convinced
at every stage
you're disk has to go
where you're putting it.
Except at the very end
where you have freedom.
The freedom you have is where
the ai's go, which pocket they
belong to.
That's the only
freedom you have.
It's the only freedom
we want you to have.
OK.
So that was disk packing.
Next is Clickomania .
How many people have
played Clickomania?
A few.
Good.
It's not completely obscure yet.
So here I have the
real thing, I think
this is called Clickomania,
Next Generation.
And I want to start
a new game so I
don't have a really bad score.
So the idea is
you're going to click
on a group, a connected
group, of one color.
That group is destroyed.
And then things fall vertically.
So column-by-column.
Rules clear?
Your goal is to remove all of
the blocks, which I probably
won't succeed in doing.
I haven't played in a long time.
But let's-- I would like
to show you one other rule,
but I may fail to do so.
This kind of
checkerboarding, not so good.
Don't do that when you play.
Also very bad.
OK.
The one rule, which I
won't demonstrate here,
is if you clear a
column, then these guys
just sort of eat the column.
They just move
closer to each other.
I think usually the right
moves to the left one step.
OK, so that's-- here's a
successful execution from
the Clickomania website.
But I have done it a few times.
I just haven't in a long time.
The only rule is, the
group that you click on,
the connected color chunk has
to be of size greater than 1.
Otherwise you could just
keep clicking on everything.
So that's why the
checkerboarding is bad,
because there you
have singleton guys.
So you may have
some singleton guys.
But if you're careful, you
sometimes can get rid of them.
The question is, when can you?
And the answer is,
it's NP-complete.
So this is actually my
first NP-hardness proof,
I think ever.
Definitely of a game.
So there's a few results here.
One is that, if you have
a single column, that case
we can solve.
A single row actually behaves
the same as a single column,
because even though they're
asymmetric in general, for when
it's 1, they're the same.
And if you happen to know
context-free grammars,
then here's the answer.
It's not obvious that
this is the answer.
But this is saying something
like, well, it could
be you already solved the game.
That's the empty string.
Or it could be you have
a solvable game followed
by a solvable game.
You could just sort
of do them separately.
And if you're careful, they
won't mess each other up.
And then you solve
the overall game.
Or it could be you
have a solvable game
and you have the same color,
one block of the same color,
on either side.
That would also be solvable
because you could just
solve the center thing.
Then these two
guys come together.
And then you click
that group of size 2.
Or this could also happen
where you solve two things
and then three
blocks come together.
And you could also
imagine other rules.
But it turns out
these are enough rules
to capture all solvable
puzzles for one row or column.
But that's not a hardness proof
so we won't talk about it.
We have two NP hardness results.
One is for two columns
and five colors.
And the other one
is a hardness proof
for five columns
and three colors.
And these are the proofs.
This one is three partition.
This one is three set.
So we might talk about
that in the three set
section of the class.
But I'm going to focus here
on the three partition--
two columns, five colors.
Open problem is
whether two colors,
you can get any hardness.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Is it obvious
that S to SS is--
PROFESSOR: No.
It's not obvious that
S to SS is valid.
Because you worry that
when you solve one of them,
you might eat a group
from the right-hand side.
But you can prove
it's always possible.
I don't remember how
that proof works,
but you can check the paper.
Yeah.
If you look at the-- if you
ever go to the course website
and watch this lecture
or click around
the slides of this lecture,
it has links to all the papers
that I'm talking about.
So if you ever want to know
more details, just go there.
Link is right there.
You don't have to type in all
these names and Google for it.
Cool.
So this is my attempt at
drawing the hardness proof.
This was challenging.
And I should say, it's
not drawn to scale.
So it's not exactly right.
But it gives you a
flavor of what happens.
And I believe all the
braces are correct.
But it just wouldn't
fit on the screen
if we drew everything
properly to scale.
So reduction from
three partition.
We have n numbers, ai
through an integers.
We're going to
scale everything up.
We're going to scale the
ai's and t by a factor of b.
b is 4/3n.
I don't totally know
why, but you know.
It's n plus the
number of groups.
I'm guessing a larger
number would also work,
but that's definitely enough.
OK.
So basically, there's
two columns, remember.
It's always going to
stay in two columns.
It never increases.
There are some clickable
blocks, clickable groups,
which correspond to the ai's.
So for every day ai, we're
going to have exactly one block,
which is b times ai by 1.
Don't draw the
lines when they're
in the same connected component.
But technically, these
are separate squares.
There's also some
clickable things up here.
Those are not too essential.
They're basically to spread
out these red blocks.
There are n over
three red blocks here.
And there are n over
3 red blocks here.
You will never win
the game unless you
destroy these red blocks.
So for example, you could
click all these blue things,
make the red together,
and then destroy the red.
But that's not a good idea.
Because these are only,
this is a very small space.
This is a relatively large gap.
I know it doesn't
look like it, but this
is only n over 3 total.
The gap between
these two things is
b times t, which is way
bigger than n over 3.
OK, so there's big gaps
between these red guys.
So what you're
basically going to do
is make this column fall down
until the first red guy aligns
with this one.
Then you delete those two.
Then you're going
to make it fall
down farther until this
red guy hits this one.
And then you can
delete those two.
Just two at a time.
And we're going to bring it
down until the third guy hits
third guy, and then the fourth
guy hits the fourth guy.
Then the reds are gone.
Before I get to
how that happens,
let me tell you what happens
when the reds are gone.
When the reds are gone, I mean,
if there are any purples left--
turns out there won't be--
but you could click them all.
Then you could
click all the blue.
Then you're done on
the right column.
So right column was
finishable, no problem,
once you've gotten
rid of the red.
Now the left column is
mostly checkerboard.
And if you remove
the red pixels,
you're left with exactly a
checkerboard except here,
the topmost red guy.
It's white on either side.
And in general, everything
below this point
is the same as everything
above this point upside down.
And so then you can always just
click on the center, center,
center, center.
I guess you have to move your
mouse down as that happens,
but you will then destroy
the black and white part.
Total is five colors.
We've got red, purple,
blue, black and white.
OK, now this is my
attempt at showing you
how we get the red
things to align.
But the idea is simple.
The initial gap from
this guy to this guy.
And then, the gap
henceforth from this one
to this one to
this one is always
b times t plus some constant.
The constants are just annoying.
So they're not essential.
The idea is, well, I've got
to bring this down b times t.
So in order to do
that, I'm going
to click on some purple things
whose total size is b times t.
In other words, the sum of
the ai's that I'm clicking on
should be equal to t.
And we happen to know
that will be three things,
but that's not essential here.
We can just use
the simple version
of three partition, where
you're asking for sets
that happened to sum to t.
Because everything is scaled up
so big by these factors of b,
I mean, these
gaps-- you have to,
even to get in the right
proximity, you have to choose
ai's that sum to exactly t.
Yes.
So the constants are annoying
because you want to make sure--
so here's an example.
Here are, in this
particular picture,
the height of one of
these things is 6.
And so, I click on one
purple thing of size 4
and one purple thing of size 2.
In reality, these numbers
would be much bigger,
but for the picture, that works.
Then things fall.
And we get this picture.
And these red things are almost
aligned, but they're off by 2,
so I click on this
little 1 by 2 block.
And then they're aligned.
Then I can click
on the red thing.
I also click on this blue
thing to sort of advance
to the next red thing.
And then these guys fall
and I get this picture.
I could click on the
white but it won't matter.
That's just, I could do
that all at the end later.
Now my goal is to get
this red thing to here.
Again, the gap is exactly 5.
So I click on, let's say, 6.
Let's say I click on
2 things of size 3.
And so then everything falls.
And the reds align.
Then I delete it.
I also delete the
blue thing to advance.
And I think that works.
Yeah, question.
AUDIENCE: How do you
ensure that it's always
the leading red
block that has to go
with the trailing red
block on the left?
PROFESSOR: Right.
So it could be you take some
other block, other red block,
and align it with this one.
That is mostly a worry from
a construction standpoint.
If you did that,
you might get stuck.
But I claim if I did that, it's
never a problem to do that.
Because this length is, this
total extent of these red guys,
is relatively small.
The whole length here is n.
Sorry, it's 3 times n over 3.
Whole length is n
whereas all these ai's
are scaled by a factor
of much bigger than n.
Well, not a huge amount
bigger, but bigger than n.
So even to get them
vaguely to the right--
this is what I was saying--
to get this red block or any
of these red blocks
near this one,
because these things
are scaled so huge,
to get one close is the same
as getting all of them close.
If you happen to succeed in a
way that gets the reds to align
in an out of order, that would
still give a valid solution
to the three partition.
That's the point.
Because we scaled
everything so huge.
To do the other direction, say,
if you have a solution of three
partition, then there's a
solution to this instance,
there we do it in order so that
we're in control and make sure
all the constants add up right.
And that's sort of the
annoying part of this proof.
But this is a
relatively easy proof,
except for these little
additive constants
to make sure
everything lines up.
It would be great if I
could just put these reds
on top of each other.
But then they're one group and
you delete them all at once.
So I have to put these
things in between.
They have to be length 2
so that I can destroy them
whenever I want to.
And so, all these
additive constants
kind of get in the way.
But it's not too bad.
Other questions
about this proof?
That's Clickomania.
Cool.
Next is Tetris, as advertised
in the original, first lecture.
So if you haven't
played Tetris, here
is the-- I hope
you've played Tetris.
I played a lot as a kid.
You have these
tetragonal blocks.
You can rotate them.
And then you can force
drop them or you can slowly
drop them and do weird
things like that,
you know, sort of
last minute moves.
Let's see.
I don't think that's-- yeah,
the rotation centers are always
a bit funny, so you
can do cool things.
So let's have some fun.
I'll just play Tetris for
the rest of the class.
So important rule is
when you complete a line,
then that line disappears.
Although in the proof, we will
prevent that from happening,
it is a rule of the game.
That's annoying.
Also annoying.
OK, well, you get the idea.
You're super impressed
by my Tetris skills.
All right, so cool.
I used to play it on
GameBoy and then NES.
You can play it on
the green building.
This happened in 2012
finally, after it
was dreamed for many years.
I am a Tetris master according
to the Harvard Tetris Society.
This was a for proving.
I didn't have to play a game
to win this as you can tell,
for proofing NP-completeness and
maximization of aligns Tetris's
pieces played, or
minimization of square height,
we masters of the
Harvard Tetris Society
hereby confer the title of
Tetris Master upon Erik D.
Demaine on the 16th day of
the 12 month in the year 17
Ano Tetri, which is since
the invention of Tetris.
OK.
This is a proof done
early in my career
at MIT with two MIT students,
David Liben-Nowell and Susan
Hohenberger, now professors
at other schools.
This was a first
attempt at a proof.
We had many attempts at
a proof, all of which
were wrong except the last one.
Yeah, anyway, you
could try to see
what's wrong with that proof.
But here is a working proof.
This is actually not the
first working proof we had.
So there is me,
David, and Susan.
And then we published a much
harder version of the proof,
with like 500 cases, and then
these three guys read our paper
and said, hey, I think we
can simplify it like this.
And then we wrote a
joint, journal version.
So reduction is from
three partition, surprise.
So I should say,
what does Tetris
mean from a computational
complexity standpoint?
There are multiple
interpretations.
Our interpretation is, I
give you an initial board.
If you've already been
playing for awhile,
here's what you have.
And then I give you
the entire sequence
of pieces that's going to come.
And I want to know,
can you survive
maximized number of lines.
This is not yet the
approximability part
of the class, but we get some
really easy inapproximability
results, so I will mention them.
For now, it's just
can you survive.
The ceiling is like
here, a couple rows
above this initial picture.
So you're almost dead.
So it's like every
second counts.
All right?
Your goal is to fill up
these chambers, these bins,
exactly, with no holes.
So if you could
do it, at the end
I'm going to give
you a T and then
a whole bunch of straights.
And then you can win the game.
All right?
So we have n over
3 of these buckets.
Each one is roughly t tall.
There's some additive constant
to deal with some stuff,
but there's t notches.
Each of these is
basically counting
one unit of an integer.
OK?
Yeah.
The point is, if you
don't open this thing,
where are the i's going to go?
And you will only be able to
open this thing if this is full
and this is full and this
is full and this is full.
So you've got to get these
perfect so that at the top,
you can open this and
then clear everything.
OK.
So here are the gadgets
from the piece perspective.
That was the initial
configuration.
Of course, there
are no ai's yet.
So the piece sequence has
to encode the ai's in unary.
Because if there are
only a constant number
of different tetromino pieces,
so you have to encode-- well,
I guess you could try
to encode in binary.
It's very hard to add when
you're working with tetrominoes
unless you do it in unary.
So here's the idea.
We have an initial
set-up like this.
It will always have this
little thing in the corner.
And so to say, hey,
a new ai is starting,
we're going to
give you, you might
call this a
right-ward pointing L.
If you look from the
barrel of the gun,
then it goes to the right.
So that makes a
nice flat face here.
Because the next piece that's
coming is a 2 by 2 square.
So what you're going to do
is let it drop all the way.
And then at the
very last second,
you slide it to the right.
OK?
And in general, we're
going to represent
ai by this pattern--
square, left
L, square, to the power ai.
Like we're going to
repeat that ai times.
So here I repeated it twice
and then dot, dot, dot.
OK?
That is encoding
ai in unary-- or I
don't know if there's
something smaller than unary,
where you use three objects
to represent one unit,
but there you go.
And then at the end
of the ai, we're
going to sort of finish
things off and reset
to this original kind of
configuration by saying square
and straight.
OK?
So the square nestles in there.
We get a straight.
And if all goes according
to plan, what you've done
is filled up basically
ai units of this thing.
And maybe plus 1.
But we know there's only three
ai's going into each bucket,
so we can deal with a plus
additive 3, that's no big deal.
And that's good.
So now you have a choice.
You have this long sequence
of pieces representing ai.
In general, the piece sequences
is the piece sequence for a1,
the piece sequence for
a2, piece sequence for a3.
The intent is, you put
all of these pieces
into one column, one
of these buckets.
The claim is you can't against
the divisibility issue.
The big issue is, can we
divide ai into two parts?
Put part of it in one bucket,
part of it in another bucket.
That would not give us a
solution to three partition.
But the claim is you can't.
And the proof of this claim is
not too hard for this proof.
It was much more tedious
for the original proof.
But basically, you
try everything else
and show that you're doomed.
So every other possible move.
So one type of bad
move, so when you
do this thing of putting
in the right-ward facing L,
remember, there's only
right-ward facing L's, there's
only n of them, one per ai.
So that's the only
sort of nice piece.
We call this priming a bucket.
Because now it has a
nice flat bottom and so,
these pieces fit nicely,
especially the squares.
So one issue is, what if
you have an unprimed bucket?
It still has this
stuff over on the left,
and you try to just
insert into it.
Because the first ai comes,
you prime one of the buckets.
What if you switch
midstream and try
to move the rest into
an unprimed bucket?
The claim is, you die.
You look at the
squares, you say, well,
if could go here
or here or higher.
And they're all bad.
This one means you'll
never fill this stuff,
so you're basically
going to run out of area.
Something's going to
have to go into the sky.
If you put this here, you'll
never get anything here.
Put that there, you'll
The squares won't fit
anymore and so on.
L's can't go pass
through that thing.
OK.
Similarly, if you try to
put a straight away in,
something bad happens.
I don't quite remember
what the bad thing is here,
but that looks-- right.
Once you cover one, you
can't cover the other.
Yeah.
It's not even obvious
you can cover this one,
but I think with some
clever rotation you can.
Tetris is a little
weird in that respect.
And then, with the
left-ward facing L's, you
can try all the things.
And again, you're toast.
So that's one type of bad thing,
where you switch midstream
from one of-- you start
putting an ai into a bucket,
and then you try to put
it into a bucket that's
currently unprimed.
So what's left is, if
you stick to one bucket,
do you have to play
like we want to play?
And so, in the
sequence of pieces,
when you haven't
placed anything,
well, maybe you try to prime
it in a different way and then
that opens up something else.
Then you'd have to go
through that entire analysis
in the last side again for
however the unprimed bucket
might look.
But it turns out, however
you do it, you're toast.
You've hidden some square which
you won't be able to open up.
Unless you do it the right way.
And once you've
done that piece, you
check that the next piece
has only one place to go.
Obviously if it's to the
left, then those are not good.
And then, the next
piece and so on.
So you check all these things.
And you conclude there's
really only one way
to play this sequence.
Except for the flexibility of
when a new ai stream comes,
which bucket do I put it in?
We're assuming here
infinite dexterity.
So you can slide to
the left and right,
pick the bucket you want,
and then let it fall.
Questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you set
up the infrastructure
so that if you leave even
one space unfilled, then
you're going to die
before you get the T?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So the idea is that if you
leave any square out here,
you will be in trouble.
And there are probably
many ways to do this.
And I forget exactly
what we do in the paper.
I think the easy one would be
that, if you put any square up
here, you die.
So you're right at
the limit of the game.
If anything doesn't go into
a bucket, you're in trouble.
And then it's just
a volume argument.
So you've got all these pieces.
The total volume
of them is exactly
the sum of the bucket sizes.
So if you leave any
blank space, that
means that the
material that was there
is going to somehow
end up on the top row.
And then you're dead.
I don't remember if that's
exactly what we did,
but that certainly
seems to work.
Adam?
AUDIENCE: If you place something
to high, but at the same time
finish a line, do you die?
And assuming not,
could we force our way
through the block early?
PROFESSOR: I believe
in real Tetris,
if you clear a line, that
happens before you potentially
die.
I don't think that's
an issue here,
because you won't be
able to clear anything
until the T piece.
So I think you use the
argument I said up to here.
There are no other T's
in the construction.
So any other piece you try
to put in here, I think,
will get you above this row.
And then you die.
So that's essentially
unusable space until the T
And then, up until
that point, you
have to exactly
fill all the stuff.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So if we
ignore filling the lower
stuff in the main
gadgets and just
stick something up
high and just try
to fill just the
tops of each of them,
so that with and L or something
we can clear one space of the--
PROFESSOR: Oh, I see.
You could try to put an
L like that or like this.
Yeah, but it if the row
clears first-- all right.
Now I have to look up
the rules, I guess.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I think it might be
OK because then there's no way
ever to fill the next part.
PROFESSOR: Let's talk
about this offline.
I think there's something to
check here, which hopefully we
did in the paper.
But I've by now forgotten.
Just for fun, if you
succeed, at the end,
you get all of these
right-ward facing L's.
Then you get the T.
Those lines clear
and then you get all the
I's and it's so satisfying,
all those Tetrises.
And then, if you're-- so a
Tetris is when you get four
rows in one move, which can
only be done with the straights.
So this is, if you
survive, then you
clear a whole bunch of columns.
But if you want to make
it really embarrassing,
then you put this
entire construction
over a nice big wall,
big empty space,
and you put a whole bunch
of pieces at the end,
like let's say L's all of the
same orientation or something.
Those are really easy to pack.
So if you want to
maximize your score
and you don't solve
this thing, then you're
really going to lose bad.
Because if you do
solve this thing,
you're going to
get tons of points
by just playing in here forever.
So n to the 1 minus epsilon
of the game is down here.
And if you can't solve
this thing at the top,
then you're getting a
score of basically zero.
I mean, you do
place a few pieces,
but very small compared to the
number of things down here,
you place like n to
the epsilon pieces.
Whereas if you do succeed, then
you get to place all n pieces.
This is just the
initial configuration,
or which floating square?
This thing?
Oh, this one.
That is possible to
construct, I believe.
This is a challenge.
It's a whole industry of
making cool initial patterns
by playing a lot of things.
So in fact, there's a paper
by Hoogeboom and Kosters
that shows that any
reasonable Tetris
configuration can be constructed
from an initially empty board.
And so, what we get is
to approximate Tetris,
let's say the number of pieces
that you play, less than n
to the 1 minus epsilon
factor is NP-hard.
That's what we just
showed or sketched.
So this is an example of an
inapproximability result.
This is a relatively easy one.
We just need to assume
P does not equal NP.
And we get that you
really can't approximate
within a very good factor.
It's sort of all or
nothing in this game.
Later in the class, we'll
see much more subtle
inapproximability results.
Other questions?
Hopefully no more issues.
There are a lot of other
open problems about Tetris.
You mentioned construction.
What if the board
is initially empty?
Seems like quite a challenging
problem, constant number
of rows or columns here.
We assume that both dimensions
are arbitrarily large,
it's part of the input.
But these seem very annoying.
Interesting.
If you just have straights, I
imagine Tetris is pretty easy.
So how many of the
Tetris pieces do you
need to get a harness
proof or are there certain
small combinations
that are easy?
We need this ability to
slide at the last minute.
Be nice if you could just
always be hitting space bar
and always drop your pieces
from positive infinity.
We don't know whether that
problem is NP-complete.
That might be the
most tractable,
but it's proof would have
to be a little different.
Two-player Tetris,
online Tetris where
you don't know the
pieces in advance,
that's something we might
get to later in the class.
But these are all open.
OK.
So next topic is
in graph theory.
So suppose you have a
graph, vertices and edges,
you want to draw it in the
plane of no two vertices
touching, no vertex on an edge.
That's a regular
notion I'm drawing,
but edges are allowed to cross.
If you're lucky,
graph is planar.
Don't need any crossings.
There's this notion of
1-planarity, which goes back
to the '80s, where
every edge can
cross at most one other edge.
So this is an example
of a one-planar drawing.
Some edges don't cross
anything, but any edge that
has a crossing only has one.
OK?
So this is NP-complete.
On a notion of strong
here, there's no numbers.
This is from 2007 and a
reduction from three partition.
So here are two gadgets.
This is a double--
well, OK, we'll
get to this one in a moment.
Here's a gadget which
is the complete graph
on six vertices, K6.
And the idea is that we're
going to plug this in instead
of a single, bold edge.
So wherever there's a bold
edge here, what it really means
is this gadget.
OK?
This is meant to be
an uncrossable edge,
because usually an edge can
take up to one crossing.
What we're going to replace
this edge with this thing,
which has a bunch
of crossings in it,
no matter how you draw it.
K6 is very symmetric,
so it's not
too hard to argue about
the different drawings.
We see a crossing
there, a crossing there,
and a crossing there.
And in general, if you look
at any path from this vertex
to this vertex, you
visit a crossing.
There's no way to get--
wait, what about this one?
What do I mean?
If I attempt to draw
an edge through here,
I will hit an edge that
has a crossing on it.
That's what I want.
So in other words, it's
not possible to draw
an edge across here
and still be 1-planer
So this effectively becomes
an uncrossable edge.
This is notation.
This is super useful.
When you have a
complicated construction,
if you use the
right notation, it's
not necessarily so complicated.
If we drew this everywhere
in these pictures,
it would be really hard
to see what's going on.
So we use this visual idea
that this is a symbol for that.
And then we can draw
really simple pictures,
relatively simple pictures.
the thing to the end of
the thing over there.
I mean, this looks
a little bit weird
like, OK, how do the ai's choose
which side they're on here?
Well, they just choose
whichever side they're on.
If they're in the
bottom chunk over here,
then they'll just connect to
the bottom chunk over here.
If they're in the
top chunk over here,
they'll connect to the
corresponding chunk over there.
This is basically
to force the ai's
to start on the outside
of this construction.
So there's a lot of, again,
there's a lot of cases
here to worry about, about
other ways you might draw this.
Maybe you'd take
this entire picture
and stuff it into
this little triangle.
They all end up with lots of
crossings on a single edge.
If you do that,
then you have to go,
you have to cross this edge
many times, for example.
I think we convinced ourselves
that with a single wheel,
without this extra thing,
the construction, I think,
we are not certain about
whether the construction works.
There's definitely
more cases to consider.
So at the very least,
it simplify things
by adding a second wheel.
It would also mean you'd have
to have multiple edges here
between the same two vertices.
So maybe that's why they
did the double wheel,
so that you have these
paths of length 2 connecting
the same thing instead
of the exact same edge.
Anyway, so again,
you have to proof.
This is essentially
only one planar bedding
for each of these wheels.
And for these things to
connect them together.
And so, the ai's have the
freedom of which bucket
they go into.
But because each of these
edges can only be crossed once,
each unit of each
ai-- only one unit
can occupy each of these cells.
So you get three partition.
Cool?
Yet another way to
represent numbers in unary.
Question?
AUDIENCE: I don't understand
how-- what those numbers are.
PROFESSOR: So OK, so these are
the ai's-- A1 is 2, A2 is 3,
A3 is 3, A4 is 3, A5
is 4, and A6 is 5.
And they are represented
by, this thing is a 2,
this thing is a 3, this thing
is 3, this thing is a 4,
and this is a 5.
And that should be
in the same sequence.
I think I missed this 3.
Good.
OK, that was 1-planarity.
Four minutes-- which
proofs to cover?
I will wave my
hands at this one.
This is a chain of blocks
with hinges on them.
And it has colors on it.
Your goal is to form a
particular pattern of colors.
I find it interesting,
this is our hardness proof.
It's interesting in that
it's-- a lot of the proofs
you've seen, it's all
about making the ai's being
a straight line.
Here, that's not a big deal.
We've sort of drawn out--
this is, again, a kind
of universal construction.
You could build any
polyomino with it.
It's all about the colors.
And so, the idea
is that the ai's
are represented by how
long of a blue segment
you have here in the
overall chain of pieces.
And these are the buckets.
And so, you just
come in at some point
and fill in however big
your ai is and then leave.
And there's just enough
blue to cover all the blue.
So you'd better not waste it.
But all the other stuff, you
have a lot of flexibility.
So it's all about just kind of
filling these amorphous blobs
that have exactly the right
area to fill these blue regions.
And there's three times
you're allowed to visit.
And that gives you
three partition.
So I want-- it's
hard, especially
without a physical
model, to understand what
the rules are at this game.
But it gives you some
idea of another way
to represent three partition.
Next, you may have seen
this kind of object.
It is called a
carpenter's ruler or rule.
It's got hinges.
It's got rigid bars.
And usually, when you're
not using it-- I mean,
you can measure lengths,
that's the ruler part.
And when you're not
using it, it folds
into this nice, compact form.
It's great.
And everyone used these
until the invention
of the retractable one.
Though they still use
these a lot in Europe.
So has unit length in this case.
But what if you have a really
annoying carpenter's rule
and the lengths
are not all equal?
And you have this nice box which
is unit length or, you know,
some length.
You'd like to fit your ruler
into that one-dimensional box.
Let's ignore the thickness here.
OK?
Then this problem is hard.
It is weakly NP-hard.
You can solve it in
pseudo-polynomial time.
So this is what-- this is like
one of the very few problems
we'll see of this type.
And this is the proof.
It's one of the simplest proofs
from reduction from partition,
which is two partition, which
is divide your numbers into two
groups.
And I apologize here.
In this book of ours,
we use x instead of a.
So those are ai's.
So you're given some ai's.
And the idea is,
well, if I would
like to partition the ai's
into two groups of equal sums,
like so, that's
the same as saying,
well, some of the ai's, or the
xi's, are going to go left.
Some of them are
going to go right.
And whether I fold something--
I could either leave it
at 180 degrees or I could
fold it to 0 degrees, that's
sort of my binary
choice if I'm going
to go into one-dimensional
box-- if I fold it,
I change direction.
If I don't fold it, I stay
in the same direction.
But what that really means is,
by something running summation
thing, I can choose for each ai
whether it goes left or right.
OK?
And then, this is
gonna-- if this happens,
what it means is my starting
point is equal to my ending
point.
Now, could be in between.
I go left and right and
who knows what happens.
But the point is, if they sum up
to the lefts equal the rights,
then my starting point will
be horizontally aligned
with my ending point.
So that's not the problem.
The problem is to fit into
a box of a given size.
So this says nothing
about the box.
But, if you do this very
simple construction,
which is add a super-long
length and then add
half of that at the beginning.
And then, at the
end, you add half
of the long length and
then the super-long length,
and your goal is to fit
it in a box of equal
to the super-long length, that
will be possible if and only
if these are aligned.
If they're not aligned, then
if you go halfway left or right
and then add the
super-long length,
if it's not aligned
with this one,
then you'll be a
little bit too big.
And you won't fit in the box.
OK?
So that represents
two partition.
Cool.
20 seconds, one more proof.
So here's another problem.
Map folding.
You've probably
done this before.
Easiest way to refold a
roadmap is differently.
Generally, what we're
interested in here
is just very simple folds.
Fold along one line, then fold
along another line and so on.
OK?
So, this is NP-hard.
If I give you a
crease pattern, this
doesn't look much like a map,
but we can talk about that.
If I give you a map, a polygon,
and some creases on it.
And I want to fold
all of these creases,
this is possible if and only
if two partition is solvable.
Notice these lengths--
here we used a's.
That's smart of us.
So these are the ai's
down the distances
between these creases,
consecutive creases.
And again, the idea is, well,
I can fold each one or not.
And just like the carpenters
rule, I can fold or not.
And if I am clever and I do
it with the right choice,
then this endpoint.
Will be vertically aligned,
have the same y-coordinate
as this endpoint.
And if I do that--
and again, we've
added half of the
super-long length and then
the super-long length here.
There's also the half
of the super-long length
and the super-long length there.
And now I can fold
these two folds.
So when I fold one,
it's going to go here.
And it won't hit anything if and
only if I solve two partition.
Right?
Again, this is the box that I'm
trying to fit everything into
and this is the
thing that I'm trying
to shift up and down to be
perfectly aligned with that.
If I can perfectly
aligned it, then I
fold this, miss, then fold
this and it's out again.
And then I can finish
these other creases
that I haven't folded yet.
OK?
So it's all about when do
you execute these two folds?
And so I'm going to do some
of the horizontal folds
so that things fit nicely.
Then I'll do the
two vertical folds.
Then I'll do the rest
of the horizontal folds.
And that will work if and only
if two partition is solvable.
Now, this may look
like a weird map,
but it turns out if you have a
regular rectangular map-- this
is not maybe a regular
one, but-- and you
have some diagonal
folds, 45 degree, then
that will basically force you
to fold something like this.
Oops, I did it again.
One, two, and then here.
So you can put in
diagonal faults
to force you to fold into
this initial structure.
And then add folds
on top of that.
So this is like
composing two gadgets.
Then you add horizontal
and vertical folds
just like that picture.
And then you'll have
a rectangular map
with horizontal, vertical,
and diagonal creases
that you can fold all the
creases by simple folds if
and only if two
partition is solvable.
Open problem, is this
strongly NP-hard?
We don't know.
Is there a
pseudo-polynomial algorithm?
Obviously we don't know.
It's quite tantalizing.
But this is basically why maps
don't have diagonal folds.
And that's it for today.